inside of mediocre online presences want
to showcase your work in a way that
truly represents your brand and
creativity then look no further than
Squarespace our sponsor for today's
video as the only one platform for
building a website Squarespace is
everything you need to make your online
presence shine stick around for more
about them in a bit it's a World At
Large Captain Kidd is regarded as one of
the most dreaded pirates in history
often mentioned alongside the likes of
Blackbeard and Henry Everett to those
who learn his story though William Kidd
becomes a much more complex and
controversial figure even a tragic one
it seems that although he chased Glory
Fame and Fortune he wanted to do it as a
legitimate captain and not as a criminal
he tried to resist Crossing that line as
long as he could but in the face of
adversity great Misfortune and a
mutinous crew captain could seemingly
turn to the dark side
foreign
kid was born Circa 1654 in Dundee
Scotland to John Kidd and Bessie bashart
oh we should mention that other places
such as granac have tried to lay claim
to her being the true birthplace of the
infamous Captain Kidd however during his
trial kids own written testimony said
that he was originally from Dundee in
the Kingdom of Scotland so we presume
that he knew his own place of birth plus
the city also has a record of a sailor's
pension that his mother received after
his father died when he was five years
old as is the case with most of the
other pirates that we've covered here
the early life of William Kidd is pretty
obscure since he came from a poor family
raised by a Widow on a sailor's pension
he didn't exactly hold the keys to the
city options were limited and he needed
to find work from an early age so after
a few years of basic schooling it is
likely that William Kidd took to the
Seas just like his father consequently
we now enter a black hole when it comes
to his life story and we emerge from it
decades later during in the mid-1680s
when Kidd was already an experienced
Seaman in his early 30s at that point
kid made his way to a tiny Speck of land
off the coast of Hispaniola in the
Caribbean named
there he met his future companion and
arch nemesis Robert califer sailor from
Cornwall and the duo struck up a
friendship as they were both looking for
work on a vessel they found it upon the
sound Rose a French Privateer captained
by Jean phantal that came into port to
recruit crew it wasn't an ideal position
as his tradition aboard friendships the
crew was predominantly well French while
Kidd was the only Scottish sailor
alongside a dozen or so Englishmen but
Beggars can't be choosers and her work
was pretty scarce at the time since all
the maritime nations were at peace with
each other piracy was always an option
but you know what they say once you
raise the black you can't go back and
kids seemed particularly inclined for
life as an outlaw privateering of course
was basically legalized piracy where a
ship received a letter of Mark from a
governor that entitled it to attack and
plunder vessels in coastal towns that
were deemed enemies of the state the
downside was that you could only attack
approved targets and yet to kick back a
share of the spores to the government
but on the other hand you didn't have a
noose waiting for you when you got back
home so that's a plus even though things
were quiet at the time there were
Rumblings of War breaking out between
France and the Netherlands so ultimately
Kidd decided that he probably did not
have to wait until there was some action
to be had so he signed up with the Sarah
Rose and went out looking for Dutch
merchants
during his voyages the San Rose ran into
a French Fleet led by Admiral
Jean-Baptiste de Cass like them the
fleet was looking to cause some trouble
for the Dutch so kid's ship joined them
as they sailed to Suriname on the
northern coast of South America which
was called Dutch Guyana at the time on
the way there though they stumbled upon
a big juicy Target a cargo-laden vessel
coming from Havana just one problem
though it was Spanish not Dutch even at
the best of times the line between
piracy and private hearing can get a
little hazy Sailors tend to get pretty
Rowdy when they are left bereft of booty
for far too long the French really
didn't want to lose this prize so they
found a loophole since the sir Rose
technically didn't hold a valid
commission only they would bake the
capture the other ships would simply
observe with their cannons pointed out
the Spanish vessel then if somehow the
plunger would get divided equally and
end up in the cargo holds of a whole
French Fleet it would indeed buy a
fortuitous series of unexpected events
no sense in arguing about it at this
point since the deed was already done
and wouldn't you know it that was
exactly what happened except that the
crew of the Sorrows abandoned their
former vessel and upgraded to the faster
a better armored Spanish ship afterward
they continued on to Dutch Guyana to do
what they actually sailed there to do
and attack the Port Town only to
discover seven armed Dutch warships
sitting in the harbor eagerly awaiting a
little dust up the French Fleet got
walloped pretty badly by cannon fire and
sailed away with its Mast tucked between
its legs the fleet was trying to decide
its next move when the stunning news
reached it in July 1688. England had
declared war on France in fact pretty
much every European Maritime power had
done so triggering the nine years war or
the war of the Grand Alliance this
created a bit of an awkward situation
for William Kidd and the other British
crewmen who now found themselves sailing
with the Enemy but the French seemed
cool about it they assumed that everyone
aboard valued plunder above patriotism
and that this new war simply gave them
more targets to attack this however was
a miscalculation on the part of the
French as their British crewmen were
more loyal to King country than expected
or once the war had started to cast his
Fleet attacked the island of Saint
Christophers now called some kids back
then jointly owned by the French and the
English they launched a full-scale land
assault leaving behind only a handful of
men to watch the ships on the vessel
commanded by Jean vantar this included
William Kidd and all the English Sailors
since they generally stuck together once
all the land troops were out of sight
and the tide was out kid gave the signal
to strike the English crewman sheep
their daggers and attacked the remaining
Frenchmen who were taken completely by
surprise throats were carton backs were
stabbed as the British threw their
former comrades in the water and
prepared the ship to cast off kid and
his men had just stolen a ship from a
French Fleet and headed for the
neighboring British Isle of Nevis there
they received a hero's welcome and were
invited to drink with the governor where
William was introduced for the first
time in his life as Captain Kidd are you
a Creator looking to build a website
that truly represents your unique brand
and style well look no further than
today's sponsor Squarespace with over 40
design options and easy drag and drop
features creating a professional and
unique website has never been easier
plus Squarespace is mobile ready and
responsive design ensures that your
website will look perfect on any device
but that's not all monetize your content
in a way that reflects your brand
identity with member areas from
Squarespace and with built-in SEO tools
like meta descriptions and keywords your
website will be easily indexed by search
engines and quickly found by your target
audience Squarespace also offers
automatic backups top quality hosting
and 24 7 customer service and with an
extensive library of how to's you'll
always have the guidance and support you
need don't take our word for it you can
try Squarespace for yourself with their
free trial and when you're ready to
launch just go to squarespace.com
biographics to save 10 of your first
purchase of a website or a domain trust
us your audience will thank you and now
back to today's video
it was Now official the ship that kid
had stolen was renamed the Blessed
William and he was appointed the new
captain the Blessed William joined a
small Fleet commanded by the local
Governor Colonel Christopher
codderington by Christmas the fleet was
joined by another Privateer captain
hewards and who together or with kid LED
an assault on the French island of
Marika Lance as a revenge for the attack
on Saint Christopher the following year
kid locked horns with his former running
mates led by De Cass and mounted a
successful Rescue of some English troops
who had been taken prisoner Hudson oh it
was very complimentary of kids skills in
Naval Warfare later writing that kid was
with me in two engagements against the
French and fought as well as any man I
ever saw back in the English Isles
Captain Kidd was hailed a hero and
feasted at Banquets it seemed like he
was the man of the hour but there was
one group of people who weren't
particularly thrilled with him at that
moment his own men fighting for their
country was fine and dandy but only as
long as it was rewarded with shiny coins
and precious gems risking their lives
for the English Navy was not something
they signed up for they made it clear to
kid they wanted to go pirating French
Spanish Dutch Romulan it didn't really
matter as long as there was booty to be
had kid refused so Calif had persuaded
the men to Mutiny sailing away on the
Blessed William during the night all of
a sudden kid found himself not only
bereft of his ship and crew but also of
his share of the plunger when they
sacked Marie galante he was penniless
and shipless but his reputation was
still in good standing in the Caribbean
so Governor codrington hired him to
command one of his privateers in the war
with France after a year of law service
kid was rewarded with his own ship a
modest 16-gun Sloop they captured from
the French which was renamed the Antigua
now that he was Captain Kidd again he
could travel at his leisure once more
his hatred for califord and the rest of
the mutineers still burned in his heart
so when he received word the Blessed
William had been spotted in New York
City he weighed anchor and set sail for
Revenge upon arrival in New York kid
discovered that he had missed his former
Ship by a few months but once again
found himself embroiled in someone
else's conflict kid derived just in time
to take part in the conclusion of a
bizarre episode from New York's early
history known as lysler's Rebellion back
in 1689 wealthy Protestant Merchant and
militia Captain Jacob lysler took over
part of the colony by force when he
heard that English King James II who was
a Catholic had been deposed by William
of Orange himself a fellow Protestant
lysler named himself acting Governor
fully expecting to receive the backing
of the new King William however wasn't
impressed with his efforts despite his
Protestant pedigree and instead declared
him to be a usurper and ordered to have
all Isler arrested and executed as it
happened Captain Kidd arrived in New
York the same time as the new Governor
Henry Slaughter and his support troops
commanded by Colonel in goldsby as one
might expect baiser wasn't in a hurry
for a date with the Gallows so he
barricaded himself inside the fort since
kid happened to be in the neighborhood
and had Canon's despair the real
Governor asked him if he wouldn't mind
terribly lending a hand kid accepted
although ultimately approved unnecessary
nicer eventually surrendered peacefully
presumably at the insistence of of his
own weary Garrison who had no interest
in fighting their own countrymen just to
keep him in power Eliza was arrested and
executed for treason Slaughter became
the new governor of New York and Captain
Kidd was once again hailed as a hero for
saving the colony from tyranny New
York's wealthy merchants were
particularly grateful and Captain Kidd
found himself as the guest of honor at
many Banquets shindigs who to nannies
and box socials a one such function kit
made the acquaintance of Sarah Bradley
Cox ought one of the most beautiful
desirable and wealthiest widows in town
the captain put his Scottish charms to
work until after just a few months of
wooing the former Widow became Sarah
Bradley Cox ought kid the marriage also
turned William good into one of the
richest and most respected men in New
York so for the next few years he was
content with living the life of a
colonial Patrician he bought some land
and a couple of daughters and served as
a respectable pillar of the community he
still kept the Antigua ready for action
since England and France were still at
war kid had a private hearing commission
from the New York Governor to attack
French ships that got too close to their
Shores and he later received a similar
commission from Massachusetts
but this life proved to quaint and too
quiet for a man of action like William
Kidd and ultimately he decided that it
was time for a career change
in 1695 kids sailed to London hoping to
secure a captain's post with the Royal
Navy this was phenomenally ambitious
even foolhardy the Navy had a pretty
strict promotion system maybe if you
were the son of a lord you could skip a
few steps but kid was the son of a dead
Scottish sailor and as far as we know
had never served aboard a royal Navy
vessel and now he was hoping to be made
captain of his own ship right off the
bat this was never going to happen in
fact kid couldn't even secure a meeting
where he could be told no to his face
but Destiny soon provided him with
another opportunity while in London he
ran into some Merchant acquaintances
from New York and they knew a friend who
knew some friends and together they
hatched a plan to obtain a privateering
commission and a new ship for kid to go
hunting for pirates and a Frenchmen a
man named Robert Livingston we presume
orchestrated the whole thing and got
some very influential noblemen to Pony
up the dough to build kid one of the
most powerful ships prowling the Seven
Seas a three-mast 32 Cannon 287-ton
warship called The Adventure Galley
Captain Kidd even signed performance
bond for twenty thousand pounds
guaranteeing that some to his backers if
I'll deliver kid was liable for the
money himself which meant that he could
not only lose his fortune but even end
up in debt as prison clearly he was not
lacking in confidence but in the
immortal words of Han Solo great kid
don't get cocky in April 1696 the
adventure I was ready to sail but not so
fast said Captain Stewart of the HMS
Duchess a while navigating its way
through the waters of the mouth of the
thams the adventure failed to follow
proper Royal Navy etiquette of Dipping
the flag or pulling the canvas out of
respect when passing a superior and
Stuart o is the kind of man who took
umbrage to such Behavior
Ernie wasn't shown the proper deference
he ordered the duchess to fire a shot
across the bow of the adventure Galley
then he came aboard the ship and
informed the captain that he would be
press ganging his 30 most experienced
Sailors into service and this was
something that Stuart could do as a
royal Navy Captain Kidd appealed to the
Lord Admiral who eventually ordered
Stewart to return the men to the
adventure but the Navy Captain still had
the last laugh although he wrote turned
the same number of men it wasn't the
ones he originally press gagged instead
using the opportunity to unload his 30
laziest and most Troublesome scurvy Sea
Dogs on Captain kid not an auspicious
start for kids career as a pirate Hunter
and things were about to get worse he
had made quite lofty promises and needed
to plunder a lot of ships in order to
hold up his end of the bargain it made
sense for the adventure to sail where
the Pirates were so it set course for
Madagascar which was supposed to be one
of the trendiest pirate havens of the
day except that by the time kid got
there the party was over and everyone
had left that simply weren't any Targets
to be had on top of this many men were
starting to show signs of scurvy while
the adventure itself wasn't faring
particularly well since it had been
built hastily and on a budget kid had no
choice but to dock while his men rested
and his vessel was patched up he then
sailed to the nearby Camaro Islands
which served as a stop-off point for
ships from the East India Trading
Company kid hoped to find a peaceful
Island where he could Karina's ship for
extensive repair says instead he
encountered a violent storm that further
damaged the adventure and an outbreak of
Cholera that killed 40 of his men within
a week other crewmen decided to leave
kid's command and to top it all off the
captain learned from passing ships that
rumors were spreading that the adventure
had raised the black and turned piracy
it was hard to think how things could
get any worse for Captain Kidd but then
he also started to deal with the looming
threat of mutiny his men oh are getting
fed up with enduring storms outbreaks
and months at Sea with nothing shiny to
show for it they better find something
to plunder soon
or else
Captain Kidd and the adventure Galley
spent 1697 in and around the Indian
Ocean with many of his best men either
press gangs or fell by cholera kid had
no choice but to replenish his ranks
with Sailors of dubious reputations
every now and then the adventure did
take a prize but nothing big enough to
keep the men happy with each passing day
kids crew was getting more and more
discontent and the idea of mutiny became
more likely on one occasion after
refusing to attack a Dutch Merchant
because it wasn't a valid Target the
captain got into a loud shouting match
with the ship's Gunner William Moore In
the Heat of the Moment could throw a
bucket at Moore's head fracturing his
skull and killing him a day later but
this Outburst of violence did little to
quell the tensions bubbling beneath the
surface with over two-thirds of his crew
wanting to turn pirate kid understood
that he couldn't swim against the
current forever he risked Mutiny or even
worse so ultimately kid relented and
thought maybe it would be just this one
time to his credit kid picked a hell of
a target a giant Indian Trading vessel
called the Quade are Merchant in late
1697 the ship filled its cargo hold with
cotton and left Sarat in Northwest India
rounding the southern tip for arriving
in Bengal there it sold its goods and
started on the journey home with its
coffers full of gold and silver as well
as valuable Goods such as silk and
muslin it was certainly an inviting
prize that would tempt any
self-respecting pirate on January the
30th 1698 the adventure captured the
quadar merchants off the southern coast
of India no fighting was necessary the
merchant vessel was traveling with a
pass issued by the French East India
Company Kidd was aware of this and
raised the French flag and boarded the
ship without violence the quadar
merchant was an Indian ship hired by
Armenian merchants and captured by an
Englishman despite this kid hoped that
he could argue back home that the fact
that it was under the French Authority
made it a valid Target after all
governments back then had a tendency to
play dumb whenever a privateer got a
little too overzealous but little did
kid know that the wind was now blowing
in a different direction for start as
the war was over England and France were
peace once more and eager to show that
they were serious about stamping out
piracy but even more importantly the
quadar merchant had ties to the emperor
of the Mughal Empire himself orang Zeb
just three years earlier Henry ever
replundered one of the grand mogul's
ships causing serious damage to the
relationship between England and India
the last thing the British crown needed
was a repeat of that disaster so as soon
as word got back home of what Captain
Kidd had done all hell broke loose and
several Men of War were dispatched to
hunt the pirate Hunter
after the prize kid traveled to
Madagascar against the island of Saint
Mary the adventure had seen better days
and was in desperate need of repairs
again once their kid found another ship
named lamoka free had already docked in
the harbor he asked around who owned it
and the answer was like a Twist straight
out of a Shyamalan movie the captain was
a pirate by the name of Robert califord
by pure happenstance kid had run into
his old crew mutinied against him and
stole his first ship this time Captain
Kidd had the advantage he had a crew of
115 and three ships at his disposal not
only the adventure but also another
vessel called November and the quadar
merchant which kid had kept and renamed
the adventure prize now was the time for
some Revenge right well unfortunately no
when kid informs the crew that he
intended to attack colorford add the
marker frigate to the fleet and sail all
four ships to London where he would
divvy up the loot his men insisted on a
vote and they voted against him 100 to
15. it seemed that one big rise had not
been enough to wipe clean the two years
of frustration that preceded it and the
crew would rather stay Pirates and
joined colorford who triumphed over kit
again this time without even doing
anything Kidd had lost his command to
Mutiny once more although this time he
was at least able to convince his former
crew to let him and his loyal men keep
the adventure prize and their shares of
the loot Captain Kidd made it to the
West Indies in April 1699. he wanted to
sail to London or New York but had
become acutely aware of the political
brouhaha that he caused when he captured
the quadar merchant in fact the year
prior King William III decreed an act of
Grace offering pardons to all Pirates
Who willingly surrendered there were
just two exceptions to the proclamation
one was Henry Avery and the other was
William Kidd the captain left his ship
in the West Indies and secured passage
to New York he hoped that he could still
argue he acted lawfully as a privateer
but it was clear that the crown Was Out
For Blood kid was arrested and sent to
London where he stood trial on five
counts of piracy and one for the murder
of William Moore during his trial Kidd
refused to is back as the men who paid
with the adventure Galley and helped him
secure his privateering commission he
naively hoped that his loyalty would be
rewarded but they did the exact opposite
completely distancing themselves and
using him as a scapegoat unsurprisingly
William Kidd was found guilty on all
charges and was executed on May 23 1701.
the fate of his ship became a mystery
until 2007 when the wreckage was
discovered near the Dominican Republic
Del's of buried treasure helped grow
Captain Kidd's Legacy to the point where
he became one of the most notorious
pirates in history although the
legitimacy of such a title remains a
bone of contention to this day